hey guys so today we're going to take a
look at some of your favorite features
coming out in ios 16. now as with normal
apple scheduling we can expect ios 16 to
be publicly released around the time of
iphone 14 which is usually in september
so we're getting an early look right now
at the beta i'm pointing to my laptop
but this has ventura on it this is my
iphone that has ios 16 on it now with
all things beta software there might be
some things that might not look the same
when it actually is fully released but
for now this will kind of give us a
pretty good look at what we can expect
hi justine here editing the video that
you're watching right now i came out
with a really cool plug-in pack for
final cut pro premiere and davinci and
it's called n keynote by motionvfx i'm
so excited about it i've been using it
in a bunch of my videos thanks everyone
who has purchased the pack already and
even shared some of your content with me
that you have used the plugins in it
looks incredible and it's so exciting to
see it getting used in the wild if you
guys want to check it out it's called m
keynotes by motionvfx and there's titles
there's transitions there's all kinds of
really cool boards there's backgrounds
all kinds of fun stuff to really spice
up your videos it's all drag and drop
super customizable check it out and let
me know what you guys think so the
number one thing that you guys had was
your favorite is the new customizable
lock screen you can change the clock
font the colors the wallpapers and you
can even add widgets focus mode filters
is a new way to link up your lock
screens with a specific mode so you can
have one for if you're sleeping working
or you just don't want to be disturbed
you can set those up however you like in
the lock screen customization settings
so here's something i already have set
up and it's really cool because if you
use a portrait mode photo this will kind
of overlap on the numbers so it'll look
a little something like this and it does
a cool little animation you can see all
of these different ones where i've
changed the font added widgets and i
love these little emoji options that you
can add too so let me show you how to
add one we'll just go to this new screen
add new you can use people photo shuffle
emoji weather astronomy and different
colors i'm going to show you how to add
the emoji one this one's really cool so
let's pick a couple of emojis and it'll
give you different variations you can do
a small grid you can do medium grid
large grid
rings or spiral i think that i like this
one so let's let's keep that now this is
where you're able to add your widgets
let's add some stocks let's add some
news and let's add my calendar let's
change this to be a different color
that's beautiful okay maybe it's not my
best work we can try again you have the
option to set this as a wallpaper pair
so not only will be on your lock screen
you can also customize your home screen
so this lets you have
legibility blur to blur the background
so you can actually see your icons or
you can just keep it just like that
there it is there's your lock screen
there's your home screen another thing
that i like is you're able to use these
portrait mode photos so here's one of
myself and i'm actually holding up a
samsung so that's kind of ironic you can
crop the photo move it around and you
can kind of place it over the time so it
gives this cool little overlap feature
you can add different filters so it'll
automatically change the colors and the
fonts for you
another thing that i like is being able
to set these focus filters so if i
decide that this moon is my nighttime
sleep focus every time i put that lock
screen on it'll automatically say that
i'm sleeping one of the other features
is an imessage and this is the unsend
and edit messages feature this is super
exciting and it's kind of interesting
because i think a lot of people are a
little confused as to how this works
you're able to send a message and you
can unsend that message within 15
minutes now this will be marked as
unsent so the person that you sent this
to will know that you unsent a message
now this isn't something that you can go
back and unsend old messages it's only
the last message and you have 15 minutes
to do so it'll also remove the
notifications but if somebody's already
seen the message then i mean they've
seen it as with unsending you'll be able
to edit the text as well so if you've
sent someone the wrong date or the wrong
time you could just go in and edit it
just like the unsend they will also be
alerted that you did edit the message i
also like that you have the ability to
mark messages as unread i am the type of
person that i won't read a message until
i know that i can have the time to
respond to it so being able to mark that
as unread which is my last message that
says ivan sent a message this is a
really cool feature and i'm definitely
excited to use that so kind of in those
same lines of unsending a text message
in the mail app it's also getting an
upgrade so you'll be able to schedule
emails you'll be able to cancel delivery
and you'll be able to get follow-up
reminders the next one we have max is
saying that he's excited about copying
images off of the background and oh i'm
also very excited about this and i'm
very surprised how well this works you
are just going to hold down and it gives
you this little
option to copy
or share it so i'm going to copy it and
i'm going to
paste it to jenna
there it is so it makes it like a little
sticker so you also can touch and hold
and then you can drag it around and then
you can also just open up whatever app
you want to drag it into and you can
drop it in and there we go now lockdown
mode is something that i really hope i
don't have to use it's a way that you're
gonna be able to completely lock down
your phone as a security precaution for
anyone who might be at risk of being
hacked or targeted most message
attachments other than images will be
blocked link previews will be disabled
incoming requests like facetime calls
are blocked if you haven't already sent
someone else a message or a call and you
won't be able to use your phone with a
wired connection or accessories people
have so much information and data on
their phones that if they are in this
situation where they are being targeted
or hacked most people don't really know
how to handle that situation so being
able to have a simple easy way to
completely lock down your phone and your
device is going to be really really
important for a lot of people this is
one of my favorite features the new
notification design yes i'm very excited
about this and there's an example of the
notifications that pop up from the
bottom it's so cool and i love this
because this is like where your thumb is
when you're holding your phone so you'll
get easier access to those notifications
so far testing this out with
notifications on the bottom
huge fan another feature you guys are
excited about is shared photo library
now this is something i'm also excited
about because i feel like anytime i'm
with my family we always take a ton of
photos and then we just kind of spam
them in our text messages which is great
now because i love that i'm able to
download all of them and you're able to
do the shared with you feature but this
is even more specific like i could share
my entire photo library with my family
so anytime we go on a vacation we can
all put our shared photos into that
library set up a shared library
so create a shared library to combine
photos with the people closest to you
you can have one shared library whoever
creates it will provide an icloud
storage for all items so i'm gonna add
jenna to my shared library i can add all
my photos i can choose by people or date
or i can choose manually so if i do
people let's see so all of the photos
with jenna will now be shared with her
oh my god 23 000 items that's a lot of
jenna photos i can also choose manually
i'll share this picture with her this
cute doggy with her i can preview my
shared library there it is and there is
our shared library and it's cool because
i can also go in here and i can do my
personal library i can see both
libraries the same time and now i can
share the link with her and there you go
we have our shared library pas keys is
also very interesting and this is
something that many of you said that
you're excited for this is going to let
you use face id or touch id instead of a
password your password will be stored
securely in the cloud and only be able
to be retrieved with your biometrics
instead of a password definitely looking
forward to hearing more about this and
of course trying it out the health app
will now have support for medications so
you'll be able to track and get
reminders when it's time to take your
medications and you'll be able to get
alerted if there's any type of pill
interactions with others that you might
be taking thankfully i am off my blood
thinners now so i'm not taking any
medications but if i ever do have to go
back on them i will be so excited to
have this pill reminder because
remembering to take them at the same
time every single day it's definitely
not easy and i would love to be able to
just mark off that i took it so in my
mind i will know and have a record that
i did take the pills continuity camera
is one of the things that i'm very
excited to try out and this is something
that you guys also said that you're
excited about this is a little disc made
by belkin it is magsafe and this is what
is going to allow you to attach your
phone to your macbook as a webcam so
i'll just put this on
just like so this little ring pops out
as just this so we're going to put that
right there where your webcam would be
and now this is already giving me an
option to use my iphone as a webcam
continuity camera lets your iphone be a
webcam for your mac when both devices
are near each other access these
features in control center you can do
center stage portrait mode studio light
and desk view both your phone and your
macbook have to be logged into the same
wi-fi and the same apple id and up here
in the video section you can choose
iphone 13 pro
and it should switch and there it is yay
okay so now i'm using the rear camera of
my iphone as the webcam this is so cool
i can also use that as the microphone
and then i can go over here and i can
change my video effects so i can turn on
center stage so when i move
oh look at that it moves with me
we can turn on the portrait so i can
have a nice blurred background even
though my background is all white see
that that's a blurred light
no portrait
oh we can also do studio light look at
that
oh that made the lighting look amazing
oh
yeah hello and it changed like the color
oh this is great now this is what i'm so
excited to try this
is desk view okay share with desk view
when screen sharing show both the top
down view of your desk and your face at
the same time okay continue
so here
is
a question out a little let's put some
headphones here
look at that ah desk view is so cool
i've also got some apple stickers
um i've got a knife
isn't that nice so i can adjust this a
little bit too so you can see
more of
my desk
magsafe nice love that this is so great
this is so cool because i'll actually be
able to use my iphone as a webcam for
conference calls and this will give you
the ability to make this built-in webcam
on your laptops so much better so all
the features that i showed you guys here
today are coming out in a future release
of ios 16 which should be out in
september give or take a few days we
don't ever really know the actual timing
of these releases but this will be
something you'll be able to get on your
iphone 14 and of course that desktop
view and other sort of features like
that will be available in mac os ventura
if there's anything that i missed that
you think that i should have covered in
this video please leave them in the
comments below and let me know what your
favorite features are that you're
looking forward to checking out i will
see you guys in my next video hit the
bell to be notified when i post new
videos and i will see you in the next
one bye
[Music]
you